well by now you've done some work in New
York you've done some sessions and some
recordings it's a podcast in New York
including one that Adam and Sona and I
want to talk to you about because this
hasn't happened at the time of this
recording but we all feel a little
what would the word be sad jealous
jealous yeah I don't know what you're
talking about I honestly don't the three
of us have a massive crush on Matthew
Reese and we just want you to send them
our love
yeah I don't know if I can do that oh
come on yeah why well first of all my my
time is very valuable and Matthew Reese
is I mean God it's such a brilliant
actor
and raconteur I just love that he's
coming on the podcast so to waste time
saying hey before you get going there
are these people you don't have to do
before you can be after yeah the first
time he was on it was over zoom and I
think we all sort of fell head over
heels yeah and uh none of us are gonna
be able to meet him in person yeah yeah
here's how it's gonna go
my plan is that if Matthew Reese ends up
being on this podcast a total of six
times yeah none of you will ever meet
him come on do you purposely plan really
cool I mean we've had a lot of really
cool guests but sometimes when you
really get someone you know we're gonna
love and then you do it somewhere else
and we can't be there you did this with
all of it the second time you had one in
New York yeah he was on New York because
oliphan and I it's a it's a special time
when we're together I was cool with the
way that one worked out yeah
I got to spend a lot of time with him oh
congrats another segment with us now
wait a minute to be fair when I
interviewed Tommy Lasorda you guys were
here
um
you weren't even here for that no I
ever there is an older baseball manager
I always make sure that you guys get to
meet I just think we're a team yeah
sometimes you go Rogue and I and I get
it it's your podcast and stuff but still
it's our podcast I just happen to be the
star
is that did that come out right no it's
um I I don't know did it I guess I just
want to meet Matthew Reese so do I and
you're getting in the way you're you're
blocking all of us you're pod
blocking us I'll tell you what I'll do
if you guys can write me a little
message or something to him we could
record a little message for him right
now
prefer you
write a message and then just trust that
I'll give it
what do you mean you won't though you'll
lose it what would you say to Matthew
Reese that is so important dear Matthew
oh I didn't realize this was a let's go
around the table a school essay a fifth
grade essay
hi my name is Sonam obsessian you don't
know me but I watched you and the
Americans and I love you what's it like
to be married to Carrie Russell yes no
you just her name I come on hold on
that's right what's it like to be
married to Carrie Russell I love her
curls you're a lucky guy she's a lucky
girl I hope we're friends one day love
Sonam Obsession hey whether you're stuck
in traffic or streaming your favorite
podcasts that's where I come in it's
important to have a network you can
trust wherever you are say it with me
T-Mobile mobile yeah you didn't really
have to say it with me but it is your
network you know I'm excited about
T-Mobile yeah you're killing it and uh
you know who's really excited is our
good friend blay who's been using this
service blade tell us about it yeah I
have been a T-Mobile a subscriber for a
really long time it they're awesome I
download videos all the time yeah you do
you like you download a lot of videos
yeah now you've never read a book no no
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic experience for
yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's
to find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data for
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted
5G details at
t-mobile.com okay
um if that was your intention if that's
what you were going to say to him I'm
really happy that you're not going to
New York okay wait I don't say like
that to me yes I can yes I can
compliment his wife who I loved who's a
curly hair icon yeah I can right yeah
they both are yeah
I would I would start with Americans but
then I would I would really lean into
his last appearance on the podcast and
how he just blew us away with his humor
which you know you don't always get to
see because he's such a great actor and
does a lot of serious roles but he has
such a good personality so Charming was
actually really I remember him being so
nice to us I think when we were getting
him like all set up with his uh Zoom he
was just we I think we all just kind of
became best friends with him in that
moment but haven't spoken to him since
and so we'd love to I think this is all
unprofessional and and borderline creepy
well you haven't even heard mine yet oh
I'm sure this will right the boat off
you go freaky
hey Matt
what's it like having the same name
pretty cool you're from Wales and I'm
from Whittier 2W places
I really loved Perry Mason
I love you I love you a lot too if you
want to just hang out hit up my man cozy
he's got my Deets and miss you thank you
bye
um who has control over what happens
Eduardo you have these tapes now do you
not I know where they are tapes okay uh
digital recording record recordings okay
okay I don't know how do you what do you
refer to the mask recordings you have
these wax cylinders yes
um
make sure that they're in my possession
what are you gonna do with them I'm
going to hand deliver them to Matthew
Reese that's what I'm going to do and
you're going to trust that I did you
could just email it to like his friends
you can just email them to no right now
yeah do it right after this podcast nope
that's not the way I like to do it I
like to give the Personal Touch I'm
going to write a little handwritten note
with it and then you guys are just going
to trust that I gave these to Matthew
Reese do you think you purposely keep us
away because you're embarrassed of us a
little bit
uh I'm gonna say that's 80 true what's
the other 20 did I get more focus on me
oh so it's embarrassment uh that you
guys will screw it up and then there's
20 of it is me just wanting more time
with Matthew Reese one idea I had was
just hear me out we could talk to Paula
about rescheduling
let me just check my schedule and see if
that works no it's not that's not your
skill no no no no I'm entering the
priesthood shortly after we sh so um oh
and then I'm uh in the circus yeah it
doesn't work out okay oh and then I'm
working for that Zeppelin company uh for
those reasons um just relax
why don't you do this just trust that I
form a strong enough connection with
Matthew Reese that he wants to come back
and on the third go-round you guys will
get to be behind glass when I enter the
event uh
is out two just for that day no no this
podcast is hemorrhaging money because of
a certain Matt gourley's spending habits
yeah when he buys stuff now kooky stuff
at the Rose Bowl swap meet he charges it
to the podcast that's true yeah yeah he
bought a 1938 Zamboni yeah oh just yeah
it's a hipster thing I now have 36
through 48 all year zambonies yeah true
story my wife is uh her step Grandma was
a Zamboni she was heir to the Zamboni
Fortune so just is that is that true
that's true wait a minute is that really
true Zamboni I just threw out Zamboni
from my random the random part of my
brain yeah what that's a real that's a
family name it's her step grandma's
maiden name and she was a wealthy
heiress of the Zamboni family I don't
know what else to say Matthew you listen
is that pretty cool well more proof that
you should get a lot of talking time
with Matthew
I love you love Perry Mason yeah that's
great guys just let me handle let me
handle the Heavy Hitters all right you
guys are all fun when we book someone on
the podcast who was third lead in a
movie that didn't really go I'm very
comfortable with you being here but when
it's these Heavy Hitters I I think I
need to uh handle it myself you
understand and I I feel like they notice
our absence though yeah I feel like he I
feel like the way you notice the absence
of pain yes I feel like he's gonna be
like hey we're Matt and Sona and Adam
yeah and then I'm gonna be like you know
and then you have to like have that
awkward conversation what if he listens
to this podcast he's a fan what if he
listens to this podcast it could be a
lot yes listen to the podcast yeah
please so yeah some do yes some do a lot
of people do this is a very very uh
successful podcast uh but no Matthew
Reese I assure you
he's a classically trained Welsh actor
he's a
man it's a good looking guy Charming
yeah I can't wait to see him are you
gonna
what what if you guys become friends yes
what's wrong with that a lot a lot if if
anyone out of the four of us is going to
be friends with Matthew Reese I don't
think it should be you yeah I appreciate
it like we do I just don't think that I
don't know I don't think you can hang
with him and Carrie I keep bringing it
you're gonna take him to the Altadena
7-Eleven and buy him a Slim Jim I'm
sorry
and don't even get me started on you
what oh sorry this I happen to know he
restores old sailboats so you think
that's not up my alley that kind of
thing he and I will get along we'll be
fast friends you work on small toy
sailboats he works on real sailboats so
the man can get into anything you do oh
that is not true I am quite the semen
yeah I am I have been at Sea many a time
I uh have sailed off the coast of Boston
Rhode Island uh Cape Cod I've uh sailed
off the rough Seas of Block Island uh my
face is weathered by the salty spray and
old Neptune's iron
anyway none of you were ever meeting
Matthew Reese that's the end of this
segment we'll see okay never gonna
happen